UNSEEN SEGMENT.
WE EXPOSE THE STORIES BEHIND THE
HEADLINES.
THE FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR RAYMOND
ARROYO.
THERE WERE SOME STAGE STUMBLES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> YEAH, LEGENDARY SINGER PATTY
LABELLE HAD JUST STARTED HER
CHRISTMAS SHOW IN MILWAUKEE WHEN
THERE WAS A BOMB THREAT.
>> HOLD ON -- WAIT!
>> WHAT?
>> LAURA, I LOVE HER
INDIGNATION.
WAIT, WAIT, WITH THE SECURITY
GUARDS.
THANKFULLY THE BOMB THREAT WAS A
FRAUD.
CNN ALSO BOMBED WHILE
PERPETUATING A FRAUD.
THIS IS THEIR COVERAGE OF DAVE
CHA'PELLE'S LATEST STAGE
PARTNERSHIP IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> COMEDIAN DAVE CHA'PELLE
BROUGHT OUT ELON MUSK ON STAGE
AND MUSK WAS MOVED FOR SEVERAL
MINUTES.
>> MAKE SOME NOISE FOR THE
RICHEST MAN IN THE WORLD.
>> YEAH!
>> HE HAS TIME TO GO TO A
DAVE CHA'PELLE SHOW?
RUNNING TWITTER.
TESLA'S NOT ENOUGH.
>> HE'S ON RIGHT WING POLITICS
SO WHEN HE SHOWS UP AT SAN
FRANCISCO IN A COMEDY SHOW,
TOUGH RECEPTION.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DON'T
REPORT, LAURA?
THE CONTEXT OF WHY PEOPLE IN SAN
FRANCISCO MIGHT BE BOOING.
AND IT WAS MOSTLY CHEERS, BY THE
WAY, AS YOU HEARD THERE.
BUT MUSK DID FIRE HALF OF THE
TWITTER WORKFORCE IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
AND THEN THERE WERE THOSE
TWITTER FILES THAT NOBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT, APPARENTLY.
>> HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW -- HE'S
GIVING THEM A PLACE TO SLEEP IF
THEY NEED TO STAY A FEW EXTRA
HOURS IN SAN FRANCISCO FOR WHICH
HE'S GETTING INVESTIGATED, I
THINK.
>> A LITTLE COT.
ACCORDING TO OUR PAL, TOM
ELLIOTT, CNN MENTIONED THE
TWITTER FILES, THE GOVERNMENT
COORDINATED CENSORSHIP WITH
TWITTER ONLY 13 TIMES SINCE
DECEMBER 2.
SO THE COVER MUSK GETTING ASKED,
BUT NOT FREE SPEECH.
GONE.
>> THEY DON'T COVER IT AS FREE
SPEECH.
THEY COVER IT AS AN OBSESSION OF
RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY THEORISTS.
THEY SAID TWITTER MANAGING THE
CHAOS OF JANUARY 6, TRYING TO
MANAGE ALL OF THAT, PEOPLE ARE
UPSET.
SO THEY KIND OF BLOW IT OFF.
THEY DON'T REALLY COVER IT.
THEY COVER IT UP.
>> I KNOW YOU'RE AN ART LOVER.
HUNTER BIDE B IS THE
MICHELANGELO OF SOHO.
HE RETURNED TO THE GEORGE
BURGESS GALLERY WHERE IT LOOKS
LIKE HUNTER SOLD THREE MORE
WORKS.
ONE FIXED, $225,000.
THE ETHICAL PROBLEMS ARE
OBVIOUS.
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS ARE
ABOUT TO INVESTIGATE THE
ANONYMOUS BUYERS.
IF YOUR OWN LAPTOP BOASTS DEALS
WITH CHINA AND UKRAINE, YOU'D
THINK IT STAYED OUT OF THE
GALLERY, RIGHT?
>> NO, WAIT A MINUTE.
HUNTER HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
ARTIST.
THEY FOCUSED ON HIS ARTWORK,
THEY SAID HE JUST STARTED DOING
ART.
HE LIVES AND BREATHES ART.
THIS IS ALWAYS HIS SIDE THING.
>> LAURA, HUNTER BIDEN IS TO ART
WHAT I AM TO GOLF, OKAY?
I COULD NOT HIT A GOLF BALL WITH
A BULLDOZER.
THE MAN IS PROFIT -- THEY HAVE
TO SHOW IT, THANKS A LOT, GUYS.
THE MAN IS CLEARLY PROFITING OFF
OF HIS FAMILY NAME.
THAT'S THE ATTRACTIVENESS OF
THIS.
>> LAURA: YOU THINK.
>> BUT, YOU KNOW, HUNTER SAYS
EVERY ONE OF HIS NEW PAINTINGS,
LAURA, CONTAIN HAIKU, ONE OF THE
JAPANESE POEMS.
BE IT FROM AFAR, IT MIGHT BE
HARD FOR PEOPLE TO SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON.
BUT WHEN YOU GET CLOSE TO
HUNTER'S MASTERPIECES, HIS
INTENTION IS CLEAR -- YOU SEE
WHAT'S WRITTEN THERE.
>> LAURA: OH.
>> WHAT A NICE HAIKU.
THAT MIGHT BE THE SATIRICAL
EDITION.
>> LAURA: HOKU?
HAIKU?
WE BOTH HAVE JOE BIDEN.
IT'S THE END OF A LONG --
RAYMOND, DON'T YOU SENSE WE'RE
ALL GETTING A LITTLE BIDENESQUE.
>> I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP JOE
BIDEN.
NONE OF THE HUNTER SALES OR THE
APPEARANCE OF IMPROPRIETY, NONE
OF THAT IS DISTURBING TO JOE
BIDEN.
HE WAS IN THE CHRISTMAS SPIRIT
TODAY.
GIVING A SPEECH AT THE TOYS FOR
TOTS EVENT.
THEY DO SUCH GOOD WORK.
BUT WHEN IT WAS OVER, IT WAS UP
TO A LITTLE GIRL TO LEAD BIDEN
OFF STAGE.
HE DIDN'T KNOW WHERE TO GO.
IT WAS THE CHILD THAT HAD TO
POINT AND GO, OH, I THINK IT'S
THIS WAY, MR. PRESIDENT.
THEY DO SAY A CHILD WILL LEAD
THEM, LAURA.
THEN JOE BIDEN SEEMED TO BE
GOING TO HIS OWN SECOND
CHILDHOOD.
HE ENJOYED A LITTLE BIKE RIDE,
WATCH THIS, YOU'LL LOVE THIS.
HE GETS ON THE BIKE AND TAKES A,
YOU KNOW, TRIES TO TAKE A RIDE.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENED LAST TIME
HE WAS ON A BIKE.
THEN THINGS GOT REALLY WEIRD.
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO GIVE A GIFT
TO THE CHILD.
BIDEN WANDERED OFF WITH A TOY
FOR HIMSELF.
TOYS FOR TOT BRAINS MAYBE WITH
THIS EVENT.
>> LAURA: RAYMOND, WE HAVE TO
LOOK FOR THE GOOD IN EVERY BIDEN
EPISODE, GIVEN THE SEASON OF
CHRISTMAS.
I LIKE TO LOOK AT IT THIS WAY --
AT LEAST HE DIDN'T SNIFF HER
WHEN SHE ESCORTED HIM OFF STAGE.
SO THAT IS A GOOD
>> WELL, IT'S HARD TO SNIFF WHEN
YOU'RE IN MOTION AND THE CHILD
IS TRYING TO LEAD YOU.
IT'S A LITTLE FAR AWAY.
>> LAURA: GIVE ME SOME
MISTLETOE, MISSY.